c'est maintenant j'accueille gaspard
proust pour elle est pas belle la vie
[Applaudissements]
politique alors petit rappel la semaine
dernière le chef de l'état a parlé après
la métaphore du mois président je ne
ferai pas comme l'agité d'avant on a eu
droit moi président j'ai découvert
castorama
fameuse allégorie de la boîte à outils
après le plombier polonais le tourneur
fraiseur corrézien si c'est pas de la
déchéance quand même chirac s'inspirer
de de gaulle miterrand d'un dess
hollande de super mario
alors seule grande mesure le choc de
simplification la fusion de la justice
et de l'intérieur et sa mise en ligne
selon mediapart
quand on pense que c'est mediapart qui
vient de lancer la réforme de la
fonction publique
quand même donne franchement si trois
journalistes web du centre de paris
arrive à faire le boulot du ministère de
l'intérieur des finances et de la
justice réunis fin tu imagines le
potentiel d'économies est
[Applaudissements]
ce que vous allez vous tout les
fonctionnaires dans la rue c'est à dire
et puis les intermittents fayolle a
beaucoup qui rêve d'avoir le site de
morandini pour ministère de la culture
c'est le prochain truc est bon au fond
il fallait s'y attendre c'est pas très
étonnant je veux dire historiquement
c'est souvent des moustachus qui ont
fait radicalement bouger des choses
cet avis non non non je pense aux
brigades du tigre à
capital alors toute cette affaire de
boîte à outils vite éclipsée par des
problèmes d'argent et sept accusations
indignes cahuzac auraient un compte en
suisse annoncé à singapour
alors je précise à plenel moi je suis
suisse et j'ai un compte en france et je
fait déjà l'objet d'une enquête en
suisse mais pas de la part des services
fiscaux mais des services psychiatriques
je dis ça de payer mes impôts ici parce
que je trouve ça formidable je pense
c'est super important de participer à
l'effort de redressement dans la justice
dans l'égalité du mariage pour tous we
are the world royal dutch shell et
pascal parce que attention excusez moi
mais d'être un peu engagés mais serait
que l'impôt ça sert à payer des des
hôpitaux des crèches des écoles mais
aussi des trucs bien comme les prisons
les charters la bombe nucléaire des crs
qui viennent à notre dame des landes
bastonner des punks à chiens
non j'adore payer les impôts c'est
délicieux tu sais ce que tu ouvres
l'enveloppent du trésor et que tu as
cette belle odeur si typique de
l'administration française qui vous
saisissent se mélangent d'encre de
photocopieuses de moquette et depuis
c'est le cadrage nerfs ah les femmes de
l'administration c'est les seuls qui
arrivent à cumuler acné ménopause
puis une fois les enveloppes ouvertes on
détache le type on voit le montant est
comme tout le monde on ajoute à 0 pour
le pourboire de moscovici
alors cahuzac a laissé une lettre dans
laquelle il se dit dévastée par le
remord alors c'est sûr s'il avait placé
un peu plus de fric en suisse et va
peut-être pas eu besoin de rester en
france
françois hollande a réagi le président
de la république prend acte avec grande
sévérité des aveux de jérôme cahuzac
tout de suite ça ça calme
je sens que tous les ministres vont
fermer leurs livrets à
il ya ce petit truc qui paraît que
cahuzac était insoupçonnable
un chirurgien esthétique directeur de
clinique privée qui a une société de
conseil pour l'industrie pharmaceutique
qui prend sa carte au ps dire comme
indice de suspicion il faut quoi en plus
et hollande qui dit qu'ils savaient pas
qu'ils pensaient que tout le monde était
propre ça c'est vraiment un truc c'est
moi candide de la république au lieu de
lire jojo lapin et le club des cinq je
ferais mieux de relire les misérables
en tout la question maintenant c'est
quel avenir pour jérôme non mais c'est
vrai qu'avec un nom pareil tu diras par
se recycler dans les eaux minérales
frontières elle prend sa source en
suisse enrichi aux éléments pompe et à
singapour et qu'elle s'appelle huriaux
cahuzac
c'est un peu agaçant comme le retour de
la morale et de la transparence je veux
pas être désagréable mais si tous les
hommes politiques sont pures et
irréprochable il ya forcément une partie
de la population qui va pas se sentir
représentés
cyclisme hidalgo talonné par bmx allons
pardon hein quand même
alors ces deux styles très différents
c'est une jolie bataille c'est très
vraiment c'est entre le jeu de
domination entre la blonde diaphane bobo
à cheval hier et la brune latino
caliente façon jello cuir latex boules
de geisha un commerce équitable
ah ça va être du propre pour nourrir les
fantasmes plus fort qu'un club sm
lesbien opté pour une séance au conseil
de paris
non je sais pas pour faire une polémique
mais il paraît que vous êtes à la
retraite depuis 2011 ça fait polémique
mais moi je vous comprendrez c'est
mérité vous avez quand même lancé le
vélib paris plage les couloirs de bus
qu'enfin le baron haussmann à côté c'est
stéphane plaza
[Applaudissements]
football la presse félicite le psg pour
son match nul face au barça comme quoi
bien l'encadrer peut encore fournir de
beaux spectacles l'immigration
certains ne cautionneront pas mais c'est
pas grave made in france le créateur du
ciré jaune est décédé mais le créateur
de la mouette qui chie court toujours
tunisie incarcéré pour sodomie c'est
quand même sympa la justice tunisienne
quoi on condamne un type pour un acte
auquel il pourra s'adonner librement en
prison
une bonne nouvelle peut être oui cécile
duflot est né un 1er avril
donc si ça se trouve elle est vraiment
fictive alors
pas belle la vie et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez
vous je m'étais 1 pouces bleus